KL I hear you have something Pierson
pharmaceuticals Arthur Denning global
corporation we know after dating
personally for fraud you're gonna accuse
the man worth eight and a half billion
dollars of manipulating drug trials yes
sir and I fight to win understand you're
in possession of files that are
illegally stolen from my computer the
woman who brought that evidence to you
where is she now I was on his laptop and
I found dad about the clinical trials
that went bad you didn't documented
payouts
tread lightly you are blaming fire no I
can't stay it's just a drink I'm married
what comes next is our secret you made
an enemy you don't want I I was just
getting cozy with your life don't ever
ignore my phone calls or I'll tell her
what happened
I have been able to reach of you I have
no idea what you're talking about Emily
matters like this would take things into
my own hands the door
he's a fugitive at large the entire city
is hunting for this guy
I didn't kill Emily
any good lawyer will tell you done
matter you the risks but you proceeded
anyway who is this i think i figured i
did this i just need to prove
I'm not gonna watch this fall apart
that you are done around at home how far
are you willing to go to get her
in this
it's better to go too far and not far
enough